bon encore une animation et c'est un
refrain qu'on ne cesse d'entendre depuis
deux semaines dans les bureaux d'un
traiteur de la haute garonne les
dernières annonces gouvernementales ont
chamboulé les fêtes de fin d'année d'une
profession qui compte sur cette période
pour remonter la pente
enfin c'est la cinquième vague les pots
de fin d'année ne sont en effet pas
recommandé actuellement la situation
qu'on vit
un petit peu démoralisante pourquoi
parce qu'on était reparti dans une
activité que je considère normal voire
plus
on avait une projection sur la fin de
l'année notamment sur le mois de
décembre
très intéressante pour notre activité
concernant les soirées de fin d'année
d'entreprise des volumes relativement
important
donc il y avait vraiment de l'
enthousiasme par rapport à tout ça et on
a perdu plus de 50% notre chiffre
d'affaires sur le mois de décembre on
n'a pas beaucoup de projections sur le
premier trimestre 2010 22 donc je vais
pas vous cacher qu'on est inquiet
thibault fayer regrette que de simples
recommandations fasse fuir ses clients
selon lui des interdictions claires
aurait été préférable la ministre du
travail elisabeth bornes a déclaré le 26
novembre que les repas d'entreprise
pouvaient avoir lieu mais dans le strict
respect des gestes barrières les
traiteurs semble aujourd'hui écrasé sous
le poids de ses responsabilités
on conçoit que cette cinquième vague et
la présente il faut prendre les
précautions on a toujours mis tous les
éléments
remplace port du masque de nos
personnels de service toutes les
protections nécessaires
les respects de distance
portionné les prestations aussi pour
éviter les plats à partager voilà
jusqu'à certaines prestations qui se
sont annulés pour la veille où on a
bien évidemment tout dressé il ya des
marchandises qui sont hachées qu'il faut
stocker qui sont périssables donc on
subit un peu tous les traiteurs sont
touchés comme d'autres métiers de
l'événementiel à blagnac à quelques pas
du site d'airbus restaurateurs ne cache
pas son embarras sa proximité avec
l'entreprise aéronautique lui assure une
clientèle d'affaires fidèles mais ces
quatre prochaines semaines il devra se
contenter de petites tables pour
compléter ce tableau déjà bien sombre la
danse est interdite dans les bars et les
restaurants et là on n'a absolument plus
rien notre récent est passé d'une
activité où on faisait 100 120 couverts
notamment le vendredi
35 aujourd'hui par exemple tous les drh
des entreprises extérieures pour se
couvrir sur non et puis parce qu'ils
n'ont pas à assumer aussi tous ces
problèmes demandent à leurs
collaborateurs de lever le pied sur les
sur les repas de groupe les repas
l'équipe donc ça sa grève est une grosse
partie de notre chiffre d'affaires là on
est à quasiment 60 % de baisse des
mesures restrictives en vigueur jusqu'au
6 janvier prochain et pour ceux qui
persisteront avoir le goût de la fête le
gouvernement recommande deux mètres de
distance par convive lorsque le masque
est retiré